Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. Here is a caller furious with me
that I said yesterday.
You know, new nuclear could be a bridge to
sustainable renewable power.
This this caller is very angry.
Take a listen.
Speaker 4: What the hell are you talking about?
Go nuclear.
You seem like Donald Trump when he talks about
clean coal, good things.
No such thing, David.
They haven't figured out what to do with the
waste that we make from current nuclear plant
technology.
Metal containers leak after thirty, thirty
five years on the ground, leaking liquid radioactive
waste into the soil.
And you're talking about new nuclear.
He's cutting something to the audience.
There's no such thing as new nuclear, no such
thing.
The bottom line is we've got to get out of
coal and oil.
That's what we've got to do.
Speaker 1: So this is unfortunately a case
where the end goal we agree on, but we disagree
about the possible role of nuclear.
Listen, I'm not a nuclear activist.
I'm not going around saying let's bring on
new nuclear.
I'm not doing that.
I think that we could given that we can't
just get off of oil right now, I think we
should just build up, go straight to renewables.
But I concede that I would be lying if I said
there was no case to be made for new nuclear
as a bridge, the fears about safety from the
70s do not apply to new nuclear technology.
If we were to use it, used fuel can be recycled
in ways we did not previously know that it
could.
More than 90 percent of its potential energy
still remains in the fuel.
After five years of use in a reactor, we are
learning more and more about storage, including
dry cask storage.
There are new, safer nuclear reactors that
include sodium cooled fission as well as advanced
fusion.
The fission technology reduces nuclear waste
and can even use the waste as fuel.
So I'm not saying nuclear you wants to do
it.
I'm saying the reflexive anti-nuclear standpoint
of some on the left is based on 40 year old
technology and understanding of how nuclear
works.
That's it.
That's all I'm saying.
So let's all relax.
All right.
Let's let simmer down on the bonus show today.
We are going to talk about a number of different
things, including this trading frenzy, another
meems stock, AMC stock doubling.
We will talk about Rhonda Santurce forcing
forcing cruise ships to accept unvaccinated
passengers.
What?
And the state is seeking 30 years for Derek
Shervin for the murder of George Floyd.
Derek Chauvin is asking for time served and
probation.
That's a big gap.
We'll talk about all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show.
I would love it if you got access to the bonus
show today by becoming a member at Join Pakman
Dotcom.
The Memorial Day special code goes until tomorrow.
It is Memorial twenty one.
Really strong discount.
All right.
I'll see everybody on the bonus show momentarily.